summer travel is going to be here before
we know it and 8 news now anchor Kirsten
Joyce connected with the experts at
going.com to really get the lowdown on
travel Trends both internationally and
domestically for the summer as well as
the best time to plan your trip
the number of passengers going through
TSA lines in recent months has reached
and sometimes exceeded pre-pandemic
numbers people booking international
flights have also booked sooner than
they typically would travel expert Katie
nastro says it's a result of them taking
advantage of deals or also because
Travelers can book with confidence
knowing they can change their travel
plans without that 200 change fee you
can actually book an economy ticket
maybe months in advance and then if your
plans should change you can bank that
ticket or just change it for a different
flight with no penalty now the
Goldilocks window to book international
travel for the best deals about four to
ten months out but who's really thinking
of booking summer travel in January
nastro says demand for flights across
the Atlantic up 14 since pre-pandemic
and to meet all this demand major
airlines have increased capacity Delta
has announced 75 percent of its
international flights have already been
booked for the summer as for
domestically here's a look at some deals
right now on full service airlines out
of Las Vegas out of Las Vegas you can go
to Honolulu for 288 round trip Vancouver
for 199 round trip or maybe you want to
go to Puerto Rico for 292 round trip if
you're eyeing some domestic flights for
this summer and you can't be flexible on
dates book them now as the prices aren't
going to get any better if you can be
flexible Mastro says consider booking
the first two weeks of June for travel
or last two weeks in August as these
flights tend to be 40 percent cheaper
than traveling in July
now domestically the best time to book a
flight to get the cheapest deals are
three to seven months ahead of your
travel plans